hey youtubers this Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's arrow and flash Q&A just a
quick reminder on the schedule has
changing just a little bit so next week
there will be a new episode of the flash
its episode seven there will be no
episode of arrow it's going on breaks so
bow shows can catch up with each other
the crossover episodes will both air in
two weeks and then the week after that
both shows will have episode 9 which
will be their midseason finales I'll
talk more about that after the QA so
let's get to some questions careful for
spoilers in case you're not cut up on
both of the episodes but lots of
questions about the arrow crossover as
well as the atom costume question number
one Chris McWilliams ass are they going
to be changing Ray Palmer's powers since
shrinking can come off a bit silly in
this day and age so what's gonna be
happening with Ray Palmer is is that
they're just gonna sidestep that whole
thing with him shrinking and doing crazy
powers he'll have the suit so he'll
probably have some abilities but they'll
all be really practical that means like
super strength maybe enhance speed think
like the exoskeletons that exist in real
life that the military uses if you
remember during Dark Knight Rises Batman
even hooked himself into an exoskeleton
because his bones were so weak Bane was
this giant dude who totally overpowered
him but when Batman put the exoskeleton
on it enabled him to match his strength
that being said just because they're not
doing powers for the atom on arrow
doesn't mean they couldn't give him like
super jumping ability think leaping tall
buildings in a single bound just to make
a Superman joke I don't think they're
gonna go straight-up Iron Man with it
but it'll be something close to that
question number two Darion asks how they
gonna make a flash versus arrow work
flash can destroy arrow in a flash
before he can shoot an arrow I'm glad
you asked that I know a lot of people
had this question so just remember that
people's powers are all dependent upon
their abilities to use those powers even
though Barry Allen has powers doesn't
mean that he is an expert at using them
think about how many times he's got his
ass handed to him on the show so far
that's that if someone messes with his
mind and he goes nuts team flash will
know how to take care of him remember
how Cisco said he built that cold gun
that captain cold stole to neutralize
flash because they didn't know whether
Barry was gonna turn out good or bad
they do have contingency plans to deal
with someone with Barry's powers on the
show I think it'll be a combination of
Stephen Amell outwitting Grant Gustin
as well as something that team flashes
give him question number three Doctor
Who gaming asks do you think that iris
will die the only way I think that they
would kill her is if it was part of a
time travel story they could kill her
but only if Barry went back in time
changed things and then she wasn't dead
they're not gonna kill her off the show
like she's not gonna leave the show iris
is one of the core characters to the
flash mythos he'd be like arrow killing
Laurel off for good question number four
errors and conduct asks why did they
bring a new love interest for Thea he
serves no purpose he actually kind of
answered your own question there he's
gonna be like the new romantic foil for
Roy I think there's something else going
on there too the real reason he's there
is to be part of Thea's arc so that she
has more of a story this season he's not
just gonna be a DJ he's a recurring
character he even has a name on the show
so I'm thinking he's going to be
involved with one of the villains on the
show either that or he's gonna be
working for Merlyn he could be working
for Amanda Waller he could be working
for the League of Assassins he could be
working for vertigo there are a number
of people he could turn out to be I
think the biggest complaint about him
was the contrived way he came into the
story it was like that Saturday Night
Live skit when will the bass drop where
Andy Samberg plays that douchebag DJ
that it's the bass drop button the funny
thing about that scene is is that Cupid
the actress that plays her said that
they didn't record it with any music
like the ad of the music at post so
there was no sound going on whenever she
was doing her phone call dialogue
question number five belly puffy asks do
you think that Laurel will play a part
in the crossover episode only on the
arrow side she's not gonna be going on
the flash show not every single
character from arrow is gonna go on the
flash and vice versa it's just gonna be
the core members I'm not sure if Roy is
gonna go on the flash I haven't seen him
in any of the flash pictures that
they've posted remember it's two
episodes so even if characters from
arrow don't go on flash they will be
featured in the arrow episode and the
same is true for the flash characters
that don't come on arrow I know it
sounds a little bit confusing but once
you see it you'll totally get it and
they're going to do the same thing in
the back half of the season they'll do
another big two-part crossover question
number six
Isaac asks do you think the constantine
will show up on either show at some
point not this season it's possible if
constatine gets canceled that he could
show up on one of the shows Matt Ryan
has actually said that there's a
possibility for a Constantine movie
involving him I don't think that that
would happen
unless
Joe got canceled they have a 12-episode
pick up so they'll produce 12 episodes
and air twelve episodes
in about three or four weeks all of TV
is gonna go on break for just a little
bit so I think that's when they're gonna
say what's happening with Constantine
question number seven
breakfast in bed ass when the crossover
happens do you think the team flash will
meet and find out who the arrow is and
also maybe Arsenal yes I think that
they're gonna learn who everyone is when
team arrow goes on the flash they'll be
inside STAR Labs so they'll see you know
their base and when team flash goes on
arrow they'll see the arrow cave I don't
know how many characters from the flash
are coming on arrow but I think that
most of both teams will learn who
everyone is question number eight fire
zero asks do things will see abracadabra
on the flash so for those that don't
know he is one of the Rogues but he's
from the far future there's a theory
that he might be Harrison wells
I think that's less likely given the
stuff that we've learned but it is
possible we could see him we know all
the core rogues like heatwave we're
gonna show up in the second half of the
season firestorm is coming
they even teased Captain Atom so they
could do Captain Atom at some point too
if they can do that and they can do
Gorilla Grodd
they can do anything I know everyone's
asking about Superman and Batman to know
do not expect them to show up anytime
soon those are like the only characters
that are on lockdown question number
nine
Hosea cuz they asked if they did a
Nightwing series and placed it in the
flash arrow universe how excited would
you be I would be very excited and they
actually kind of already have done that
with a Teen Titans show the show is
called Titans it's gonna be on TNT
it'll be loosely connected to the arrow
flash universe just because TNT is owned
by the same network that owns the CW
think of it is like a Constantine Gotham
arrow flash situation they'll be loosely
connected but don't expect the actors to
go on each other's shows because of
doing Nightwing on the Teen Titans show
the live-action show he's not going to
be showing up on arrow anytime soon
question number 10 rob ruiz asks do you
think that the atom might get his own
spin-off show like the flash nope but
you will be happy to know that they do
have plans to take him on the flash when
I say that I'm talking about season two
of the flash Ray Palmer isn't gonna stay
on arrow forever it's gonna be like a
canary situation they're not gonna kill
him off it's just that he's a guest
character he's only meant to be there
for a little while so just like the
canary he has a major
arc in season three and then we might
see him like once or twice during season
four depending on how that ends up going
largely though they do have plans to
give him powers but if they did that it
would only be when he goes on the flash
of all the characters that air on the
flash are doing right now Ray Palmer is
one of those few that has a lot in
common with both the flash comics and
the green arrow comics it's just really
easy to use that character in both
universes because he's so science-based
that being said that doesn't mean he's
confirmed to be going on the flash
season two as like a main character that
probably announced what's going on
before Comic Con next year though like
who the big characters that are coming
on are gonna be question number 11 I be
hey s did Ray have a wife before I don't
know where I got that from I could be
wrong you are not wrong I know I
mentioned in my arrow video that Ray
Palmer had a tragic backstory that
they'd be explaining at some point the
wife is part of that I don't know what
the circumstances are gonna be but his
wife did die and that's what inspired
him to become a hero to build that suit
still some really big questions though
we don't know what Ray Palmer's ultimate
plan is what he's actually gonna do once
he gets that suit and what his ongoing
relationship with team arrow is gonna be
once he does put the suit on just expect
him to get an episode in the back half
of the season where they do a complete
explainer on what he's doing where he
came from and why he's building that
suit question number 12 Geoff OH&S so is
Ray Palmer already the atom like does he
already have his power so well like I
said arrow is not gonna do any powers
he's not gonna have any metahuman powers
it'll all be tech based where we're
seeing him on the show right now it's
right before that it's just like Barry
Allen becoming the flash during the
mid-season finale last year I know
everyone was kind of wondering about the
dwarf star alloy that's not gonna give
him special powers it's just gonna make
his suit super strong and super light
thank you so much though for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do like I said no new arrow next week
but there will be a new flash episode
and then in two weeks they'll be the
crossover because there's no new arrow I
will be doing a bonus video in place of
that so feel free to leave requests and
be sure to subscribe to get everything
just a quick video schedule update I'm
going to see Hunger Games tonight so I'm
gonna try and post that review tomorrow
morning and then I also have Legend of
Korra coming and if you haven't seen me
explain in the other videos I have a new
mobile feature YouTube's letting me play
with so if you're in your mobile phone
or on a tab
there are new links up here that you can
click on it's the same as the links over
here
but right now click here to catch up on
arrow this week and click here to catch
up on the flash thank you so much for
watching so I'll see you guys tomorrow
high five
you